when you're prepping for scene in the
show how does your prep process differ
when you're doing a dialog driven scene
versus one where you are responsible for
the musical number how do I live was
an interesting experience for me as an
actor it was the first time because we
actually did so episode 8 I sing and
perform six songs and how do I live I
knew was going to be very emotional for
me so I told Mandy and she said
generously was like sure I was like can
we just not involve dance with that one
I really want to be simple in that it's
just me and my dad and the expression of
what I'm going through and I look back
and I'm like was that [ __ ] up of me to
just say Mandy I'm taking this one but
she was like not we have like a good
rapport and I love her so much and I've
I've said to her in person they say to
you now Mandy if you're watching thank
you for being like sure take it
so anyways there was no dance and then
the assistant director Shay it was
really generous with me and a great
friend and she was like tell me which
ones you want to do on which day because
this is everyone knew like I had a lot
of anxiety about this episode it was
like a colossal undertaking because not
only am i performing six songs most
people do one an episode if that I was
doing six in one episode that I had to
prep all that while shooting the series
so it was really scary and I had a lot
of support from this team of people and
Shay was like which do you want to do
first so I was like I want to do how do
I live first because as an actor when
you have a scene that you know is gonna
be really emotional if like plagues you
and it's just everywhere so
by the way I know there's like a
motional comment I have to anticipate
and I can just focus on singing dancing
so it was aside how I've got the I got
the music in me it was only my second
time ever lip-syncing and this was one
dance it was like very close in my face
so I was like technically I have to just
be good at lip synching with something I
like forgot that you have to be able to
sell that the words aren't coming out of
your mouth so we do want to take and I'm
highly emotional and the emotionality
doesn't match the pre-record so even
though my lips are moving at the right
time it doesn't look right because
what's happening outside is so emotional
and the music I recorded a week before
on a on a sound studio so they were like
okay that was really good but it just
doesn't match so then I was like okay
I'll sing live and I don't care if it
sounds bad so then I do the next take
I'm highly emotional and when you cry
you know you can't breathe you know
there's a lot of guests so I can't make
noise so then the song wasn't coming out
of my mouth so I was like oh now what
and I I had an acting coach on set my
friend Megan and she was like just
breathe like to be able to sing you just
have to breathe and so then but it was
an interesting process and I did it
again and I was able to sing and cry at
the same time not that crying was
necessarily the goal but it was like
it's hard to have emotional freedom in
set choreography and set pre records
because then you have to do the delicate
balance of like threading the you you
have to it's like ADR but performing ADR
in musical and acting at the same time
on camera so it's a whole new set of
skills that I was learning on the day
and
ultimately we pull it off